why is it that publicly we're getting
pushed a much more submissive much more
agreeable much more effeminate man and
yet it seems in erotica like reveal
preferences stated preferences why do
they seem to be diverging
yeah I mean I think that in a sense you
kind of captured it with the pushing
aspect of it right like that there's
okay there is a there is a uh you know
there can be a social agenda in not
maybe wanting men or at least not
wanting some men to be more aggressive
um and we often see sort of like at
least recently sort of like negative
view of masculinity in general right
like this idea that well masculinity is
toxic or that you know men need to be
different
um which also doesn't really Jive well
with the view that some people have that
men and women are not different it's
like well if they're not different then
why are you worried about this aren't
you worried about toxic femininity
um I mean it is an interesting question
but I think that that you know uh as you
point out if if the point of that kind
of erotica is
to fulfill the fantasies of women the
fantasies of women are not about
generally men that they can push around
they're about men that are useful if the
world comes to an end
um it's it's the things that that
historically and ancestrally women
valued in men is he going to be a good
provider is he a good protector is he
gonna you know take care of my kids is
he gonna give my kids good genes that
are going to make them strong what would
you what would you say so the ideal of
the cover what would you say to the
women that are saying to you well
Catherine you know those are that's a
old Antiquated view of what women want
from men have we not transcended that
now in the new world you know I don't I
I'm perfectly happy if my boyfriend
decides to paint his nails and web holes
and and put a dress on this is this is
something now where I I don't think that
you're up with the times here sure I
mean I would say that you know whatever
floats your boat right like I mean if it
works for you
for your partner to be like that's also
perfectly fine there may be variation
between women and that but years ago
they really tried to push the
softer gentler Kinder view of guys in
romance novels and they didn't sell well
and my guess is they didn't sell well
because even if in your daily life it
might be easier to have a guy that would
do whatever you wanted no matter what
that might not be what you fantasize
about
right I mean if we think about what what
what is really appealing to us in the
same sense that of course you know men
may fantasize about women that they
would never get in real life
right if you think about the reality of
things if you're
an unattractive male who uh is older and
doesn't have any resources
you know you're not going to get the
average porn star but that doesn't mean
that that's not what floats your boat so
it is it is almost a kind of not so much
not short-term mating strategy thing but
it is an object of sexual desire that
may not match up with what you would
want as a long-term partner there may be
some differences there that women have
well mate might be what what you might
want but also might not be what you can
get right as well I think that that's
part of it because I think that every
girl who goes to a romance novel
convention would be happy to have one of
the cover models go on with her uh and
stay there
um but you know there are also you know
there are pros and cons to highly
masculine men right I mean and there's
often been this debate about
um you know when you look at at even the
hero in the romance novel I mean he's
very manly guy
um but there is that that issue is he a
cat or is he a dad and even when he
starts out as a cat he usually ends up
as a dad bad that's not always the way
it is in real life if if you find that
guy right so there's always going to be
that compromise of what are the features
that you would ideally like in your
day-to-day life and some of it may be
that some of it also maybe just what's
happening in the population right
there's always been this discussion
about whether testosterone levels have
decreased and that men actually are
somewhat less masculine than they used
to be in some ways and some of it may be
just like okay well this is what we have
and this is what we're going to work
with what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face
[Music]